a manhunt is under way for the gunman
who shot and killed a seven-year-old
girl in Houston
Jasmine Barnes was in a car with her
mother and siblings Sunday morning when
an unknown person opened fire Jasmine
was shot in the head and her mother and
sisters were wounded authorities are
still searching for the gunman in this
seemingly random attack Janet shamlian
is in Houston with more Janet good
morning good morning this search has
taken on new intensity today the
roadside slaughter of a child without a
parent motive this morning we are
hearing from the little girl's mother
herself caught in the crossfire I want
to wake up in my bed next to my child
the Porsche Washington instead woke up
in a Houston hospital room with a bullet
to her shoulder and the knowledge that
another one took the life of her 7 year
old daughter Jasmine Barnes everybody
Washington said she was taking all four
of her daughter's on a coffee run Sunday
morning when a man in a red truck pulled
up alongside them and started firing can
you think of anything that transpired
replayed this moment no she was able to
drive off only later when stopping to
call 911
realizing she and her youngest daughter
were also hurt and that her second
grader Jasmine had suffered a fatal shot
to the head detectives believe the
shooter is a white male in his 40s with
a beard they released this surveillance
video of the red pickup he was driving
now three days after what appears to be
a random unprovoked murder the suspect
is still out on the streets
something Jasmine's grieving family vows
to change we're not gonna stop looking
we're gonna brain justice
my baby there is a sense of outrage in
Houston right now over this crime
deputies have been going to local homes
and businesses
hoping to find more security footage as
of this morning Jasmine's mother is out
of the hospital it's little consolation
to a devastated family Nora little
consolation indeed Janet thank you so
much